if you look at this for a moment
i think that neville put it very well he
said
you're only limited
by weakness of attention
and poverty of imagination
i want you to think about that for a
moment really give that some thought
you're only limited by weakness of
attention
you know i have quoted
dr warner von braun on numerous
occasions
when john kennedy when he was the
president of the united states asked the
good
doctor the
father of the space program greatest
scientist
you know
what it would take to build a rocket
that will carry a person on the moon and
bring it back safely to earth he
answered him in five words he said the
will to do it
now
will is a mental faculty your perception
the will reason imagination memory and
intuition
these are all our higher faculties this
is what makes us who we actually are
this what separates us from all the rest
of the animal kingdom
and
neville's saying
you're only limited by weakness of
attention
warning ron brown was telling president
kennedy
all you need is to give it your full
attention
the will to do it
see the will gives us the ability to
concentrate
i don't know what you want
but i do know this
if you can think it
and you can let yourself get emotionally
involved with it
and you stay focused on it
you can have it
now that's a very basic concept
but it's not the easiest thing for most
people to do
but the more you study it the better
you're going to get at it
but i love this you're only limited by
weakness of attention
and poverty of imagination
you've got to activate your imagination
a lot of people just use their
imagination for gosh i hope this doesn't
happen i hope that doesn't happen
they're letting it go in the wrong
direction
our imagination is the most marvelous
he'll in in think and grow rich he'll
said the imagination is the most
marvelous miraculous inconceivably
powerful force that the world's ever
known
it's
it'll create anything for you it'll take
you anywhere
your imagination will take you anywhere
and it'll give you anything you want
that's a beautiful thing to know
want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carl michael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn the
seven habits you need to develop to
activate the law of attraction enjoy
habit number two create an internal
symphony with john ashraf the reason i
made the comment about the law of
attraction not working for 99 of the
people is because most people don't
understand the different energy systems
in the body and really how the law of
attraction works or what i prefer it to
be known as as the law of resonance
now when you have a desire
that gives you a certain feeling a
certain vibration when you really
emotionalize that desire but unless you
keep that vibration going it dissipates
it really isn't very strong
and so think about your desires as being
conscious using your imagination or
using your deductive reasoning your
ability to choose basically based on
different options what it is you want to
achieve in your life
that's part of the conscious brains
responsibility and that will emit a
small little frequency just like a bleep
of light maybe from your refrigerator
but what you really want to have working
for you are the hundred trillion cells
in your body that vibrate
based on the subconscious conditioning
in the subconscious minds
programming
and so think about
your conscious mind as the chooser but
the subconscious mind as the implementor
and the reason 99 of people will never
achieve the positive results based on
the law of attraction is because they
think positively but they have the
beliefs the habits and the values
possibly
that are not in line with each other and
so let's say you want to make an extra
hundred thousand dollars or fifty
thousand dollars or a million dollars or
let's say that you want to release the
weight that you don't enjoy on your body
or let's say that you want to find a
soulmate that you're not with right now
it's not enough just to have the idea
it's not enough just to write it down
it's not enough to have a vision board
what you have to understand is you've
got to get the conscious mind
and the subconscious mind to line up
those two signals have gotta line up so
there's something known as a coherence
pattern and when you have a coherence
pattern things are working well in
coherence just like if you were to
listen to musical instruments that
weren't in tune or musical instruments
that weren't in harmony with each other
you might make a lot of noise but you
wouldn't enjoy the benefits of a
symphony
what i want you to understand is that
you have to create an internal symphony
between the conscious mind and the
subconscious mind and between your
beliefs
and your habits because if you have the
desire and even if you emotionalize it
and feel it and you impress it into the
subconscious mind but you don't take
action towards what you want to achieve
you'll never have the law of attraction
work for you as well as it could
and so many of you are working so hard
trying and the truth is there's nothing
to try
what you have to understand is the law
of attraction always works and it works
perfectly if you're wondering what that
sound was that was my father in the
background coughing he's here from
israel right now and i'm not even going
to edit it just so you can enjoy some of
the realness of life
and so here is the key
i want you to
enjoy all the goal setting that you want
but i also want you every single day to
start visualizing what you want to
achieve i want you to start using
affirmations the right way i want you to
start to meditate every day so you're in
that frequency of abundance but what i
also want you to do is i want you to
develop a blueprint a plan for how
you're going to get from where you are
to where you want to be you see the
universe will do most of the work but it
wants you in action also
and the law of attractions last six
letters
was
action is action but not just any action
you've got to have the right action in
the right order
and then apply it
so if you want the law of attraction to
work for you you have to understand it
properly and work it properly habit
number three commit to feeling good with
gabby bernstein i've been doing all
these interviews and every time i sit
down for an interview somebody's like
what does it mean to be a super
attractor and i respond by saying it
means that you're committed to feeling
good
and the next question they asked me is
why did you write this book
and i say
because i wanted to feel good
and it felt so good to write this book i
wrote this book while i was pregnant
with my son
and i was birthing this human and this
book at the same time it was epic and i
just had this amazing experience and
this momentum and this energy and i know
that you can feel it who's reading the
book who's got the book
somebody even wrote to me on instagram
they were like i can feel like i'm
surrounded by your womb
and i was like you know you kind of are
because that's the energy i was in when
i wrote this and so we we have these
moments in our life where we're just
ready to feel good
but as we know we all experience a lot
of suffering we all experience suffering
we all have very difficult things that
happen in life we have addictions we
have health issues we have financial
struggles we have depression we have
stuff and that is real
but when we make the commitment to lean
into feeling good we can even be going
through those dark times and still have
fun along the way
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there habit number four work on your
confidence with marissa peer i want you
to work on your self-belief and
confidence
write out
what kind of confidence you will need to
have to achieve that goal
what beliefs do you need to believe to
achieve that goal you know someone said
to michael jordan you're so lucky so i
know
the more i train
the luckier i become
because you make your own luck
write out your beliefs write out the
confidence you will give to yourself
because you can fill yourself up with
confidence you were born with it you
haven't lost it you just buried it under
limiting beliefs you can remove those
habit number five accept yourself with
louise hay let's take the word should
and discard it forever
never to be heard of again
should is a word that makes a prisoner
of us
every time we use should
we are either making ourselves wrong
or making someone else wrong
we are in effect saying not good enough
or you have failed
or you are going to fail
or just wrong
begin to listen to how often this word
is used
and how crippling it is
let your understanding and awareness
grow and make you free
replace the word should with the word
could
could lets you know that you have choice
and choice is freedom
we need to be aware that everything we
do in life is done by choice
there's really nothing that we have to
do
there are things that it might be best
for us to do
however we always have choice
so now every time you hear yourself
using the word should
let a red light go off in your mind
then gently
allow yourself to release it and let it
go
please don't use eliminating should
as another excuse to get angry at
yourself
all we want is understanding and
awareness
then things will drop away by themselves
you might notice oh dear it's 27 times
today that i've said should
no wonder i'm such a rigid person
now that would be understanding and
awareness and the road to freedom
one of the worst things we can do is to
get angry at ourselves
anger only locks us more rigidly into
our patterns
sometimes we think we have to be angry
at ourselves in order to change
you may have been angry at yourself and
scolding yourself for years
and you still haven't changed
that is not the way to do it
think of what happens when we yell and
scream at a tiny child
all the joy goes out of their life
and if we yell and scream at them long
enough
they literally shrivel and sit in
corners
or they tear up the room
the same things happen to the little
child within us when we get angry at
ourselves
we lose our joy
we lose our creativity
we lose our spontaneity
we lose our freedom
and our health
we don't need any more anger
we need more self-acceptance and more
self-love
when we can accept ourselves right now
as we are right now
without any criticism or judgment
then we are truly loving ourselves
and the negative patterns must dissolve
if we wait until we have the new job
before we love ourselves
or if we wait
until we lose weight before we love
ourselves
or if we wait until someone else loves
us before we love ourselves
then we are denying our existence right
now
if we wait
until we become perfect before we love
ourselves
we waste our lives
we are already the perfect outer
expression
of our inner understanding
and
we will change
but the changes we make when we love and
accept ourselves are always positive
always
so let's release the anger
and all those negative beliefs about
ourselves and about life
and begin the process of accepting and
approving
who and what we are in the here and now
habit number six be at ease with sad
guru why do they say that you can design
your own destiny
you can
you can determine your destiny you
should that's what being human means
right
see if you had come here like any other
creature on this planet
they have compulsive cycles they live by
that it's okay for them because that's
all they're capable of
once you have come as a human being
everything that you can do
actually if you look at your life you're
not doing anything very greatly
different from what the other creatures
are doing
they are born you are born you grow up
they grow up
they reproduce you reproduce they die
you die
nothing very different but these same
simple things we can conduct them
consciously
that is the significant thing about
being human
the moment you conduct it let's say you
conduct your hand consciously
now this hand will do what you want
isn't it
you won't simply sit here and do like
this
now this will hand will do what you want
suppose you conduct your thought
consciously
now your thought will do what you want
if your thought
was doing what you want how would you
keep yourself blissful and miserable
blissful
if you are blissful would you go in
search of happiness
no if you're blissful you're just you're
blissful would your life be in pursuit
of happiness i'm asking
it'll you'll be in a state yes you're
blissful
so these things that people think are
the greatest things in their life to be
peaceful joyful nonsense wouldn't mean a
thing to you
because you're blissful
[Music]
but you can't say that to them they'll
feel insulted
you have to
you have to play with you
but essentially if your thought and
emotion was taking instructions from you
you would keep yourself in the highest
level of pleasantness whatever that is
isn't it correct yes
if that happened
if that happened your entire life
process
will come to an ease
total ease
right now this is because you have
you're a crouching tiger
you have to go get something always
there is nothing to get if you sit here
your
life is complete
now it's at ease total is
when it's in this kind of ease
it will become perceptive
now
just pursuing a profession making money
or even being joyful or being loving or
falling in love with nothing means
anything to you
because
just sitting here the highest level of
pleasantness is happening to you so what
would you do with that life naturally
you would explore something that is not
in your perception right now
this is how spiritual process begins
this is how you take charge of your life
now you wish for something it happened
i want you to know this
for most people at least 50 percent
of what they wish happens
it is just that
they are focusing on a few things that
did not happen
if you want to be fair in a reasonably
well settled society
ninety percent of what they wish happens
it is the ten percent they're
complaining about in habit number seven
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is start working hard with
gary vaynerchuk hard work and don't buy
my hard work course because there isn't
one
there's no hard work sessions there's no
hard work ebook it's just hard work like
so my answer to this is i believe in it
but then you have to make your actions
map it i want to buy the new york jets i
think about it i want it i start
building vaynermedia there's an
opportunity to sell my company sell a
piece of my company to thousands of
entities all of them pass
i then sell it for lest one entity an
owner of an nfl team
that's called putting your money where
your mouth is i didn't do that by acts i
knew what kind of life i had i could
have
dated and married a bunch of different
people but when i found what i needed
for what i really knew i wanted i went
in that direction
right like i talk about hr driven
culture and this and that and some
people be like ah you got a bad review
on glassdoor or four seven yes that's
fine but come here
watch what i do every day you guys know
my calendar you see what i do you know
what's on the back end of this like
so my belief in the law of attraction is
blake believe in it believe in it but
then you have to execute against your
belief if you want to be an esports
celebrity
shouldn't you spend every one of your
minutes
selling [ __ ] on ebay buying a ticket and
then going to the esports con not like
oh i can't go to the esports con
work
work by the way on that note we got to
pick up the musically you're just you're
a killer on it i want it i'm so into it
yes that work work work reward is so fun
i was saying right now with that like
that tone work like it's work like
there's gonna be nothing else like yes
work smart i can hear the cynicism
already i can read the comment from
sally right now but you gotta work smart
no [ __ ] sally i'm leaving rick alone for
a minute you know no
yes it's better to have a better
strategy and to work smarter but here's
the punchline nothing happens without it
and i mean a lot of it and the more you
want the more work you got to put in the
bigger your ambition the more you got to
punch that clock and you got to give up
fun and leisure and laziness and rest
and all of it so my belief is it's real
i live it
but my actions map to it it's like
intent i talk a lot about intent some of
the people internally razz me about it
they're like yeah cool but a tent
without your backing up the actions is
whack and i'm like i respect that but it
starts with intent so i believe it
probably starts with visualizing what
you want or the law of attraction or
saying it or putting in the universe
fine fine i believe in that i live it
the problem is i disproportionately out
execute everybody else i know that talks
about it and then does nothing about it
just give yourself permission
to want the things that you want and
unless you believe that you're worthy
unless that you
practice love you're never going to
think that you deserve the things that
you want
right
so tell the story
okay so i'm probably going to i mean
historically i'll shorten it i'll
shorten it so this the bottom line is
that so in 1986
i was a senior in college at dartmouth
and my parents came to visit from
western michigan
and we went to this place called simon
pierce which is a famous glass blowing
mill
and as we walked into the restaurant i
had an experience
that you may be able to relate to and
that is i walked in and i immediately
saw this painting hanging on the wall
and it was about the size of a door only
horizontal and it was a vermont
landscape
and i was drawn into it immediately like
i was no longer in that restaurant i was
standing in that field i could feel that
breeze i had never
ever had an experience like that with a
painting have you ever had an experience
like that with art no i mean
not like that not like that i mean my
yeah my sense was that this is very
atypical for you very
so
i
kind of lost it the the the restaurant
was quiet and then
i leaned back i'm suddenly kind of back
in the moment i'm like i'm gonna own
this painting someday
it just that was what was right there
and i looked at the price and said like
three thousand dollars i'm like not
today and i went back and i sat down and
that was it
but the painting never left my mind you
see there's something called the zygon
arc effect i always say it wrong but
it's like there's a checklist in your
brain
that when you
have a moment where you're like this is
important
your brain puts it on a checklist yeah
there's like a notch yes a notch happens
and now your brain as part of the filter
in the brain is always going to be kind
of scanning the subconscious to let
anything into your mind related to that
incident it can be positive by the way
like with the painting or this is how
trauma happens too like you have this
high intensity emotional experience that
notches something in your brain and now
your brain kicks in to remember
so uh
bottom line is uh
i always thought about that painting
years go by
whenever somebody would say vermont i'd
think of the painting
i don't know why i can't explain it
never wanted a painting before was not
an art student it's going to last like
you're out collecting art
no no
and so i you know fast forward the story
10 years and my uh
chris and i are are engaged and we're
going to go up to vermont to see the
leaves and immediately i'm like we gotta
go to simon pierce i gotta show you the
painting so we pull up to the mill and
we walk in and right in front there is
boom a painting by the same artist gayle
shepard and i'm like oh my god it's here
and we race all around the place
and it's gone
and the funny thing was and this is the
way your brain works
chris was more disappointed than i was
i literally turned to him and said it's
okay dude like it'd be weird if we're
still here after 10 years i'm going to
track this thing down i actually said to
him you know what's going to happen
chris
i'm going to be able to buy this like 40
years from now it's going to be hanging
in the corporate lobby of some building
and i'm going to have to track down the
owner and pay like quadruple the money
they pay but i'm going to own this
family
mission yes
so a couple years pass and um
it's my birthday i think i was turning
30 and chris says uh chris gets a couple
people to
give money and he said i could buy
anything i wanted with it so i had a i'd
what 500 bucks now i'm pregnant at the
time with our first kid
i should have bought a crib or stools
but for whatever reason the zygon arc
effect takes over and i'm like the
painting
so i call the mill
and i get this guy on the phone i'm like
uh you know i want to buy a kale
shepherd piece
and i said could you send me polaroids
and he's like sure and i tell him the
budget and he goes i'll send you
polaroids of some of her smaller things
and she's like blowing up in the
meantime right yeah she's a very very
successful vermont landscape artist and
so
i
i i say to him you know by the way
there's this one painting
and i describe the painting i'd seen
over 10 years ago and he said well that
was way before my time but i bet gayle
will know
and i'm like gayle you know gail he's
like of course i know gail she like
lives in in down the road
here's her number
so for two days i paced around the
apartment with 500 bucks in my pocket
driving chris crazy because i felt like
what am i going to say to her and i must
be a weirdo i've been stalking this lady
i've been thinking about her for 10
years i can't afford a painting you know
what who am i to buy a painting like
what the hell
so finally chris is like would you call
her i'm gonna call her you're driving me
crazy so i call her
and i start talking a mile a minute and
she was amazing
and then um i said by the way there was
this one painting and i go and i explain
this painting there's a stand of poplar
trees down the center and a big
mountainscape behind it and this
beautiful blue vermont sky and geese
flying in formation overhead and
i could hear her thinking on the other
end of the line and she said you know
mel i've done so many large-scale
uh paintings over the years i'd hate
to mistake the one you're talking about
but i'll tell you what
what if my husband and i meet you and
chris at the mill at simon pierce
and we'll walk all around and have lunch
and i'll tell you the stories behind
every painting and if you don't see what
you like there i'll take you back to my
studio which is a couple miles down the
river and you can look at everything i'm
working on and if you don't see anything
you like there then you can go through
all my slides and see if you can find
that painting that you saw 10 years ago
and i said deal
so a month passes
we go up to the mill i walk in we meet
each other she's amazing she's like
twice our age just incredibly cool lady
she's walking around as we're walking
around looking at these paintings rich
i've got i'm like eight months pregnant
i'm realizing
these are ten times the amount of money
that i have
i
can't afford this
like i don't i don't have this kind of
money
and
i'm getting like more and more into that
imposter syndrome what am i doing mode
oh my god i'm so embarrassed i'm meeting
somebody i idolize i don't deserve to be
here right wasting her time because she
thinks she's going to get a payday out
of this correct we sit down
and she goes now that you're sitting
down i have something to tell you
um
she said there's
only been two times in my career as an
artist
that i've done two studies of the same
piece and your painting is one of them
it's one of a pair
she knew all along she knew all along
she was playing games with you about not
knowing which painting yeah and she said
the sister piece to the one that you saw
all those years ago
is sitting in my studio right now where
it's been for the past 11 years
i start sobbing everybody's like totally
emotional her husband's like you should
have seen her when you when she was on
the phone with you it was like she saw a
ghost
so we get in the car
and we drive to the mill
and when we walk in there in the center
of this massive kind of barn studio
space is an easel with a
painting taped up with painters tape on
it and it was
the sister to my painting there were
slight differences not as much movement
in the
grass but it was
one of the most extraordinary
experiences of my life it was as if time
suspended and i was
standing before that painting
in 1990
saying it would be mine
and there i was 11 years later
standing in front of it
and then i realized oh my god i can't
afford this
and chris walks over and he's like
what's wrong and i'm like just promise
me someday like promise me that i don't
need a jewelry i don't need a like just
promise me you will buy me this thing
and he kind of leans over and goes hey
gail how much for the big one
and she said um
mel can have it for 500 bucks because
clearly when i was making it
11 years ago i was making it for her
and so it hangs in my kitchen
it's on the back of the book um this is
the galley though right so wait is it in
the is it i think so yeah yeah
and um
it's a reminder every day that your mind
is designed to help you get what you
want
i never stopped believing
that i could make it happen
and when you tell your mind what's
important to you
there is extraordinary science
that proves that your
mind has a live and ever-changing filter
a live network
that changes how it views the world what
it lets in what it blocks out
and if you program your mind correctly
and if you're clear about what you want
to create your mind will help you get
what you want if you tell yourself a lie
often enough you're going to start to
believe it
and way around 1900 william james said
believe and your belief will create the
fact
it's got to be believed you've got to
believe it
and if there's no belief it ain't going
to happen
see when you believe it you're encased
in the idea you fuse with the idea
and that makes all kinds of things
happen when you believe it
there's no quitting you never quit
it doesn't matter what happens you don't
quit
quitting is never an option
i
the people that quit
they never really bought into the idea
in the first place
see you've gotta you you get it on three
levels the second you think of something
you've got it intellectually
when you get emotionally involved you've
got it on a spiritual or emotional level
well then that expresses itself through
the body body's just an instrument of
your mind
and so
when you're really buying into it you
literally fuse with it neville said you
fuse with it and this causes all kinds
of things to happen
you're dealing with electronics you're
dealing with energy
like the second you think something
that's all you need see you live on
frequencies you think on frequencies
your phone operates on frequencies
and it's like magic
um
you're in romania are you right i'm in
toronto yes
if i've got your number on my phone i
could take a picture or something hit it
like that you've got it in romania
simultaneous with me sending it because
when you get into the mind there isn't
any time or space
it's just immediate
yeah well the you're living on
frequencies
now when you think of something what
you've done is you flipped your brain
onto a higher frequency the very fact
you can see it is all the proof you need
to know you could get it
what you have to do is raise your level
of consciousness to that frequency
and then you will attract whatever's on
that frequency first type of
manifestation is to get very very clear
and you know if we're not clear about
what we desire then we can call in some
really funky stuff yeah this is big and
i just want to interrupt you for a
moment because like one of the things
that i say again and again when i'm
working with clients i can help you get
anything you want but you have to tell
me what that is yeah that's it you know
and the clarity is really it's that
secret key because you're like a
manifestation can opener if somebody
gets clear about what they want that's
really fun that's your new name oh
that's not a new title i'm a
manifestation can't over yes it's true
because if somebody gets really clear
about what they want your work is just
releasing all the blocks and all the
disbelief yeah and so if you're clear
first and foremost you must be clear
yeah and and you must be clear because
if you are unclear you'll start to call
in some things that are not really what
you want you'll be confused uh the other
piece is that once you're clear you can
also then get clear about all the ways
that you don't believe you ever seen a
mustard seed here i have some here
i want to pull one out now jesus said if
you had the faith of a mustard seed you
could move mountains
and anything was possible now i heard
this as a kid and i really believed it
and so the question is what do you
believe
do you believe that you are worthy
of happiness do you believe that
happiness success abundance
comfort fulfillment peace
joy
love
is a part of your birthright
is that what you believe
or do you believe something else because
you will
manifest
the life that you believe the universe
in some way is kind of a little bit
rigged against us that's correct let me
prove to you
he's a garden now when you plant roses
what do you get
what do you get
comment below you get roses right
now what happens if you don't plan
anything and you don't take time to even
take care of the garden you don't even
pay attention to it what happens
weeds grow
so it is not the case that if you
don't plan something nothing will happen
no it's rather the case when you don't
plan anything weeds grow and that's how
our mind works so if you're not
constantly feeding your mind i call that
mind feed if you don't constantly feed
your mind with
positive motivation inspiration
something
something that moves you towards your
goals practical useful
information to feed your mind if you're
not doing that constantly weeds grow and
that's why personally i don't watch news
because most news are nothing more than
negativity and they are just
designed to grab your attention right
the design is just sensations it doesn't
actually do much to your life it doesn't
add value to your life it doesn't make
you a better person except it scares the
heck out of you you watch enough news
you don't even want to go out right you
don't want to do anything so i don't
watch news if it's important enough
guess what my team someone would tell me
i'll eventually find out but most of the
time i don't know what is going on i
focus on what i do i want to protect
this
i want to protect my filter
i'm very very careful about
how i view the world and how i upgrade
my filter and that's why law of
attraction it works all the time it
works 24 7. you cannot stop it even if
you want to you cannot stop it even if
you're not paying attention to it so you
could choose
you can choose what information you
consume every single day you can choose
what you pay attention to you can choose
what channel you watch you can choose
what videos you watch you have the power
to choose everyone visualizes whether he
realizes it or not visualization is one
of the great secrets of success that's
where we build a picture in our mind
when van gogh was asked how do you do
such beautiful work he said i dream my
painting and then i paint my dream
well that's the way it works
and all the great leaders have been
great visionaries
and
solomon said where there is no vision
the people will perish now that doesn't
mean they're going to die it just
means their results are going to get
weaker and weaker and weaker and they're
just not going to be making it happen
the way they want to
everyone visualizes whether he realizes
or not
visualization is a great secret to
success now look at this
the conscious use of this great power
attracts attracts to you
multiplied resources
multiply it attracts to you
you know something about the law of
attraction how do we attract
well through visualization
now look it
and it intensifies your wisdom
and enables you to make use of
advantages you formally fail to
recognize if you organize your mind
to a certain level of organization
it in turn organizes the whole system
your body your emotion your energies
everything it's organized in the
direction once all these four dimensions
of you your physical body
your mind your emotion and
the fundamental life energies are
organized in one direction once you are
like this
anything that you wish happens without
even lifting a little finger actually
it would help to assist it with activity
but
even without doing any activity you can
still manifest what you want if you
organize these four dimensions
in one direction and keep it unwavering
in that direction for a certain period
of time
right now the problem with your mind is
every moment it is changing its
direction
it is like you want to travel somewhere
and every two steps if you keep changing
your direction the question of you
reaching the destination is very remote
unless it happens by chance
it's very important
that our physical action
emotional action
mental action and energy actions are
controlled and properly directed
if it is not so we become destructive
self-destructive
right now that is our problem the
technology which is supposed to make our
life beautiful and easy has become the
source of all the problem that we are
destroying the very basis
of our life which is the planet
so what should have been a boon we are
making a curse out of
it what has brought incredible
levels of comfort and convenience to us
in the last
100 years or so
has also become a threat to our life
simply because
we are not
conscious action we are in a compulsive
state of action
so organizing our minds fundamentally
means
moving from a compulsive state of
activity to a conscious state of
activity how do you feel after an
interview do you walk away and go like
wow that was really insightful
i learned a lot this is wonderful take
that same feeling and hold that feeling
in your mind as you repeat that
affirmation with a visualization okay
creates a pattern in your subconscious
that starts to vibrate
at that frequency and you might have
interviewed hundreds of people and
there's some interviews that you go like
oh that wasn't that great but there's
some that you go like this is probably
one of my best take the feeling from
your best interview and insert that into
your affirmation because now it's going
to be vibrating at that feeling and then
you'll start attracting anything of a
similar vibration to it trust your ideas
believe that they're amazing and and
manifest them into the world i love it
i'm not taking it from the approach of i
want this book to be a new york times
bestseller and i'm sitting there
visualizing my book being a new york
times bestseller
i'm not visualizing myself being on
brendon burchard's stage in puerto rico
to a couple thousand people
that's not the process that i typically
go through although i'm open to that
maybe being a mistake i don't know
it's never really felt like
it's worth it i don't know i'm sitting
there i've done it many times sitting
there visualizing i've never really felt
like that made a difference
i'm open to being totally wrong but
how i do apply it and
massively seen an impact is as soon as i
get an idea for something it's it's go
time trust that vision that came to you
trust that idea that's in your head and
do something immediately about it
when i thought about the idea of having
a house of building a custom home i then
went off and built a 5 000 square foot
custom home like inside of the year we
had the whole thing done when i thought
about silly things like i thought about
having a mannequin i was watching green
arrow on tv
and i loved how they all had their their
mannequins when they were in their their
lair or their realm they had their
outfits their costumes on a mannequin
and i thought i feel like i'm i'm the
green arrow i'm i got the deep hood look
i could be this is this is the believe
arrow right
uh i want a mannequin too and then
inside of a week i had my own mannequin
here and so it may seem crazy mainstream
wild but that's how i tend to operate
and i think it's amazing
right now i'm thinking about doing a
30-day challenge on my youtube channel
my main youtube channel where every day
for the next 30 days i have a series of
videos to help you build a better life
so like 30 days to a better life
and it's going to be some of our best
work and i thought of the idea and now
immediately we're doing it and so
trusting the ideas that come to me and
then immediately creating them and i
guess manifesting them to the world i am
a thousand percent all in on
the
sitting and visualizing
the thing that i want i have a struggle
with and i'm open to
making it better and and being changed
where i face the hardest time with this
is my health so
i broke my neck last year right i wore
this for for
uh 60 days taking it off for 10 minutes
a day that was it and i had a concussion
and i had two spots in my neck that were
broken and i did some meditation with a
guy named michael edwards who
led me through this guided meditation
and he helped me and he was doing it
with me in person uh over over the phone
sending me videos and
first off was getting the concussion
away because i'd never had a concussion
before and the meditation i found really
helped the concussion the second part
was the visualization so i have a bone
in the back of my neck that broke off
so the big bone broke and it's healed
the little bone just kind of broke up
like the tip like imagine i guess the
fingernail kind of hanging loose right
and it broke off and the doctor said
it's not going to come back together and
and it's not worth going and doing
surgery on it because it's not a big
deal don't worry about it
and michael was convinced that i could
heal myself and i could make that bone
come back together and so every
night and every morning i would do it
twice a day meditating and visualizing
the neck coming back together and and
you know take some
you know hand sanitizer or not hand
sensitive take some lotion and and you
know put it on my neck and just as i'm
to get more tactical like as i'm doing
it the the bones connecting i talked to
john assaraf who is a another you know
legendary expert in his field and he's
peacefully convinced that it can come
back together through visualization
through meditation i haven't done it yet
i haven't i haven't i haven't cracked
the code on how to do it i wish i did
we did x-rays
uh 60 days later and it's still just as
disconnected it still just didn't move
a centimeter a millimeter closer
and that was honestly a little bit
uh you know negative or low or defeating
and and my motivation to do it as
intensely has
has waned i haven't been doing it twice
a day every day
i still
want to believe that is possible and i
still
kind of believe that it's possible and
maybe that's not enough maybe that's the
problem uh maybe the problem was i never
believed enough that it could happen and
that's why it didn't happen so i would i
would love for that to work i would love
for meditation to work i've meditated
with
i don't know how many different people
so many different people i've never
really felt the benefit
um
of having a meditation just feels
like i'm like i'm sitting down nothing
wrong with it just i don't feel extra
clarity or anything coming out of the
meditation so
i believe that has worked for other
people i believe that it can work for me
i haven't found the path to make it work
most people number one they get up in
the morning they check their cell phone
they check their text their whatsapp
their facebook they post something on
facebook drive to work the same way do
the same thing so from a program they've
actually lost their free will to the
program wow so if you start your day
and you start your day with this simple
question
what is the greatest ideal of myself
that i can be today you ask yourself
that question now listen your body is
going to go like well you got to get a
cup of coffee and you got to go i'm
tired yeah and you got to go ah
you're not the mind i'm the mind right
now you're going to sit here i'm going
to feed you
you're going to get your coffee you're
going to do all those things but right
now this is my time you're going to obey
me right
so now the body's no longer the mind
you're the mind and so when it wants to
get up and you become aware of it and
return back to the present moment every
time you do that's victory
you're changing some aspect of yourself
so then
ask yourself i do this all the time
write down four thoughts
that you're going to stay conscious of
the whole day i can't it's too hard
you'd be surprised the moment you become
conscious of what those thoughts are how
unconscious you've been to them all day
you know for weeks on end write down
what you speak how you speak four things
you want to change how you act how do
you how do you act you complain you
blame you make excuses you feel sorry
for yourself that's a victim
consciousness
what emotions do you live by is it
possible that you're so used to living
by guilt you don't even know it's guilt
it just feels like you
you allow your energy to drop become
conscious of those states of mind and
body and review them and say this is the
old self
then say
what thoughts do i want to fire and wire
in my brain
and start firing and wiring and start
feeling it what behaviors will i
demonstrate today what choices will i
make one day one lifetime
just like you did rehearse them
rehearse the whole entire thing begin to
install the neurological hardware in
your brain and if you keep installing it
the hardware's will become a software
programmer you start thinking and acting
that way and then here's a tough part
[Music]
can you teach your body emotionally
what your future is going to feel like
before it's made manifest
and don't get up until you feel that way
now practice that for a few days
and then see if you can stay in that
state and watch all of a sudden all
those weird doors start opening for you
producers synchronicities whatever they
are number
two take up time at the end of your day
the end of your day before you lay down
and give thanks for your life and
feel gratitude and really teach your
body what it feels like the emotional
signature of gratitude gratitude means
you're getting something if i give you
something that's of value you would say
thank you because you would feel it
right so when you're receiving
you're giving thanks so gratitude is the
ultimate state of receiving
so then people only accept believe and
surrender to the thoughts equal to their
emotional state so if you're in a state
of gratitude
every thought is going to make it right
down into your body if you're saying i'm
healthy i'm healthy i'm healthy i'm
wealthy and wealthy and wealthy and your
body's programmed the negativity it's
saying no you're not no you're not
knowing i thought it's going to stop
right here so as you elevate your state
there are about
1200
different chemical reactions that go on
in the body begin to restore and repair
the body in a state of gratitude
and so we've done the research to prove
that
10 minutes
and just feel it
with all of your heart that's it
third thing
and and very important
take time whenever it is
sit down close your eyes
and begin to just open your awareness
to the space around you and just sense
it and pay attention to it become more
aware of it if you can't feel the
emotion of your future
your manifestation of love before it's
made manifest like people say well well
when my relationship hat when i find mr
right then i'm going to feel love
waiting for the outer environment to
change
to take away this feeling of anger
resentment emptiness but they forgot
that they create reality in other words
when it finally appears that i'm going
to feel love that's that's cause and
effect we're waiting for something to
happen if you're feeling the lack and
the emptiness
then you're keeping your relationship at
arm's length because you don't have the
magnetic field
to draw to you
so
the emotions that come from these energy
centers the lower energy centers in our
body do have
frequencies there's chemistry involved
but they have a different agenda
so now we ask the person
can you teach
your body emotionally
what the future will feel like before
it's made manifest that means you can't
wait for your relationship to feel love
you have to reverse that battleship and
understand feeling love now is going to
be the magnet and if you can hold the
vision of your future a clear intention
with a coherent brain
organize signals into the field
and you could actually crack this thing
open
and
practice getting so present in the
moment
that you're not anticipating the next
moment or trying to predict the future
and you're no longer romancing the
emotions of your past you can find that
sweet spot of the generous present
moment
the familiar past is the known
emotionally the predictable future is
the habituation of autopilot being
unconscious and programs those are both
knowns there's only one place where the
unknown exists that's the present moment
so if you could work with your body
to the point that it trusts you enough
to feel so safe
that you have conquered it in a certain
way that it could actually relax into
the present moment and it's not worried
about what's going to happen next or
what's going on around around you or
that you need to eat you need to pee you
need to move you got beyond all your
drives and you're you're ready to create
that moment where you're present
if you could begin to
work with your heart
and start to breathe and start to
practice feeling love in the beginning
it would feel foolish or gratitude why
would i feel love if it hasn't happened
well that's because you've been
hypnotized into waiting for your world
to change to feel feel the emotion from
the experience
but according to the quantum model
your emotion ahead of the experience
when you combine that clear intention
with the elevated emotion and you feel
love your body's so objective
that it's actually believing it's living
in that future in the present moment and
your body now is beginning to change
you are beginning to change your biology
to reflect
what you're about to experience in your
future
so the stronger the
love you feel the more altered you feel
inside of you the more you're going to
pay attention to that picture in your
mind stimulus response
memory emotion
thought and feeling but now you're
remembering your future
instead of remembering your past if
you're truly in the present moment and
you know exactly what you want
and you
begin to teach your body emotion start
practicing opening that heart it's
amazing what happens
the moment that heart begins to open
we've measured this so many times lewis
on a on a scan on a real-time brain scan
when the heart moves into this kind of
rhythm when you're feeling
frustration
when you're feeling impatient when
you're feeling resentment you are
stepping on the gas pedal and you're
stepping on the brake at the same time
and the heart is pumping against the
closed system and it causes an erratic
beat it becomes incoherent and energy
literally leaves the heart now you no
longer believe in your future you can't
put your heart into your future you
can't trust the outcome because there's
no energy there it's it's being used and
consumed somewhere else so energy is
leaving the brain as well
but once energy starts to move into the
heart we've seen this so many times and
it starts to beat in this rhythm like
banging a drum or dropping a pebble in
water pebble after pebble the heart
begins to create a wave of energy right
to the brain like like taking a big
sheet
and going like that and then all of a
sudden you see this wave and the brain
gets this rush of energy and that change
in brain wave patterns that change that
wave is carrying information
and the person starts to get a very
clear idea they see their future very
clearly now now that energy is causing
them to move into very coherent alpha
brainwave patterns which is the state of
creation this is when you no longer hear
the voice in your head that's talking to
you that you listen to and believe is
the truth i'm not good enough
it suppresses the default mode network
and the next thing you know
you start seeing in pictures and images
you start dreaming
and that's the imagination that's the
creative state so now you start
naturally imagining the heart is the
creative center we got to put our heart
into our future it better be open and
activated
so now when you start falling in love
with your future
oxytocin is released in the brain and in
the heart oxytocin signals nitric oxide
nitric oxide signals another chemical
called endothelial derived relaxing
factor and just like when your sexual
organs get filled with blood because
you're aroused the same thing happens
here as it would happen somewhere else
and literally the arteries in the heart
and lungs engorge and now your heart
feels full and it's thumping in order
and you're
in the present moment now once that
happens and it's beating in rhythm the
heart produces an external magnetic
field up to three meters wide now
you're in survival you're drawing from
the field and turning into chemistry
when you get energy in the heart it's
causing a change in the brain
and all of a sudden it's resetting the
baseline for trauma
and now here you have a magnetic field
now the heart
is your magnet it is it is the center of
creation and now that that energy is
frequency
and frequency carries information and
you can lay the thought of your new
relationship life is a series of changes
those of us who are rigid and inflexible
in our thinking
often snap when the winds of change blow
but those of us who are like willow
trees
bend easily and adapt to the new changes
if we refuse to change then life passes
us by and we get left behind
just as a flexible body is more
comfortable to be in
so is a flexible mind more comfortable
to live in
i am open to the new and changing
every moment presents a wonderful new
opportunity to become more of who i am
i flow with life easily
and effortlessly
[Music]
i now go beyond other people's fears and
limitations
i am not my mother's fears and
limitations nor am i my father's fears
and limitations i'm not even my own
fears and limitations these are only
false thoughts that have been hanging
around in my mind
i can erase them as easily as i can
clean a dirty window when the window of
my mind is clean i can see clearly the
negative thoughts for what they are and
i can choose to eliminate them
it is my mind that creates my
experiences i am unlimited in my own
ability to create the good in my life
life mirrors my every thought
as i keep my thoughts positive life
brings me only good experiences
there is plenty for everyone including
me
there is so much food on this planet
that we could feed everyone
yes there are people who are starving
but it is not the lack of food it is the
lack of love that allows this to happen
there is so much money and so many
riches in the world far more than we
know
if it were all distributed equally
within a month or so those who have
money now would have more and those who
are poor now would once again be poor
for wealth has to do with consciousness
and deservability
there are billions of people on this
planet yet you will hear people tell you
that they are lonely
if we don't reach out love cannot find
us
so as i affirm my self-worth and my
deservability that which i need comes to
me in the perfect time space
availability
the ocean of life is lavish with its
abundance
all my needs and desires are met before
i even ask
my good comes from everywhere and
everyone and everything
all is well in my world
my life has always worked perfectly only
i did not know it i didn't realize that
every negative event in my world was
life reflecting back to me my belief
system
now that i am aware i can consciously
program my thinking process to have a
life that works on all levels
everything in my life works now and
forevermore
my work is deeply fulfilling
when we learn to love what we do then
life sees to it that we will always have
interesting creative occupations
when you are ready emotionally and
mentally for the next step in life life
will move you to it
give your best to life today
i do what i love and love what i do
i know that i am always working in the
right place with just the right people
and that i learn all of the valuable
lessons my soul needs to learn
life supports me
when you follow the laws of life life
will support you abundantly
life created me to be fulfilled i trust
life and life is always there at every
turn i am safe
my future is glorious
our futures will always represent our
current thoughts
what you are thinking and saying right
now is creating your future so think
glorious thoughts and you will have a
glorious future
i now live in limitless love
light and joy all is well in my world
i open new doors to life
as i walk down the corridor of life
there are doors on every side each one
opens to a new experience
the more i clear the negative thought
patterns from my mind the more i find
doors that open to only good experiences
my clarity of thinking brings to me the
best that life has to offer
i rejoice in what i have and i know
fresh new experiences are always ahead
of me i greet the new with open arms i
trust life to be wonderful
i claim my own power and i lovingly
create my own reality
no one can do it for you
only you can make your own declarations
in your mind if you give your power to
others then you have none when you claim
your power it is yours use it wisely
i ask for more understanding so that i
may knowingly and lovingly shape my
world and my experiences
i now create a wonderful new job
bless your current job with love and
release it with love to the next person
who takes your place
knowing that you are moving into a new
level of life
keep your affirmations for the new
position clear and positive and know
that you deserve the best
i am totally open and receptive to a
wonderful new position using my creative
talents and abilities working with and
for people i love in a wonderful
location and earning good money
everything i touch is a success
we always have the option of poverty
thinking or prosperity thinking
when we think thoughts of lack and
limitation then that is what we
experience
there is no way you can be prosperous if
your thinking is impoverished
to be successful you need to constantly
think thoughts of prosperity and
abundance
i now establish a new awareness of
success
i know i can be as successful as i make
my mind up to be
i move into the winning circle
golden opportunities are everywhere for
me prosperity of every kind is drawn to
me
i am open and receptive to new avenues
of income
when we are open and receptive life will
find many ways to bring income to us as
we know and affirm that we deserve all
good the infinite source will open new
channels
we often limit our own good by believing
in fixed income and other closed ideas
opening our consciousness opens the
banks of heaven
i now receive my good from expected and
unexpected sources i am an unlimited
being accepting from an unlimited source
in an unlimited way i am blessed beyond
my fondest dreams
i deserve the best and i accept the best
now the only thing that keeps us from
having the good in our life is that we
don't believe we deserve it
somewhere in childhood we learned that
we didn't deserve and we believed it
now it is time to release that belief i
am mentally and emotionally equipped to
enjoy a prosperous and loving life
it is my birthright to deserve all good
i claim my good now
life is simple and easy
the laws of life are simple far too
simple for many people who want to
struggle and complicate things what you
give out comes back to you what you
believe about yourself and about life
becomes true for you it is that simple
all i need to know at any given moment
is revealed to me i trust myself and i
trust life and all is well someone said
to us one day when we were trying to get
them to focus upon positive things and
we sort of laid out a list of positive
things that she might think about and
she said oh abraham i don't want those
i've already got those
and what she really meant was
the things that i want are the things
that have not yet happened and we want
to help you to realize that if you're
thinking about things that you want from
the standpoint that they have not yet
come to fruition that they are still
missing in your experience
then
you're holding it in a sort of
suspended position where the distance
between where you are and where it is is
not closing
so what we're wanting you to realize is
you have these patterns of thought and
law of attraction is helping you to
sustain
the pattern of thought that you have a
belief is just a thought you keep
thinking and so early on in your
experience by your exposure to life you
began developing some patterns of
thought sometimes they were carefully
taught to you by others sometimes it
came because of something that you
observed and then talked about and then
remembered and then attracted again and
then talked about it and then remembered
and then attracted again in other words
life is very interesting here isn't it
because you can't talk about anything
for very long before it begins to
replicate itself in your life experience
and it's what makes you develop your
patterns of what you call truths
you say
at first i wasn't sure and then i
pondered it for a while
and once i gave it my attention
i began seeing evidence of it everywhere
and now i believe it and now that i
believe it it's manifesting in my
experience and we say that's really
wonderful isn't it if it's stuff you
want
but if you are repeating patterns of
thought about things you do not want
and in your environment oh you are very
very good at that you have this
sort of mass consciousness theory that
goes like this
if we don't beat the drum of our history
we are sure to repeat it again and we
say
the contrary is true
the more you beat the drum of anything
the more you activate it in your
vibration the more it is activated in
your vibration
then the more law of attraction is
matching you up with things like it and
the more law of attraction is matching
you up with things like it the more you
observe it and the more you observe it
the more you talk about it the more you
talk about it and observe it the more
you beat the drum of it or offer the
vibration of it the more you offer the
vibration of it the more law of
attraction matches you up with it the
more law of attraction matches you up
with it the more you're living it the
more you're talking about it the more
you're beating the drum of it the more
you're offering the vibration of it this
gathering we're calling it the art of
allowing but what it really means is the
art of telling a different story the art
of telling the story the way life has
helped you carve it out incrementally
but telling the story with your words
with your observations with your
expectations with your vibration
then when law of attraction is
responding to your deliberate offering
of thought now you're getting what you
want not just what you're observing
are there things in your life that are
as you want them to be
keep telling that story
are there things in your life that are
not as you want it to be
don't tell that story
you cannot choose something that feels
better
until you are aware of what you are
choosing
so
relief is the order of business what do
you want to talk about in 1925
physicists said that our vision of a
universe split into an invisible energy
realm and a material physical realm was
a total illusion
that everything is energy the whole
thing there is no matter in this world
and to summarize what the meaning was a
famous physicist in 1930 by the name of
sir james jeans said we have been led to
believe that the universe is a great
machine
when in fact it is more a great thought
and the reality about that was quantum
physicists have established since 1925
that consciousness is the primary
mechanism of creativity of the world
that we experience in fact a more recent
article in the journal nature which is
like a
scientific mainstream journal was an
article by a quantum physicist at johns
hopkins university by the name of
richard conhenry
and his article was entitled the mental
universe
i i know the last two lines in the
article because they were like
so powerful and here's what the
conclusion of the article was
the universe is immaterial
it's mental and spiritual
live
and enjoy
and this is so exciting because science
is coming out saying it's mental and
spiritual it's like oh my god but that's
the quantum physics part
and the reality about it why is that and
so important as uh sad vijay had just
mentioned
it's our thoughts
that are manifesting this world now you
could say that's a spiritual thing and
now i say not only is it spiritual now
it is fundamental basic science of the
universe and it says then the thoughts
are creative well if the thoughts are
created then who is having the thought
and you start to realize i'm having the
thought well then the truth is simple as
richard cohn henry said
you are creating this world with your
mental activity and your spirituality
combined and then all of a sudden it
says well then if i'm creating the world
then my original belief that when things
didn't go right
i was a victim
the universe wasn't supporting me you
know it's like oh i try so hard and the
universe is not giving me things it
turns 180 degrees around
and it basically says this
we
are creating this world
and then i say your mind is creating
this world
and then i give you the science that
says there are two minds that are
operating at the same time one is called
the conscious mind and one is called the
subconscious mind i say what's the
difference
the conscious mind is where you are as a
spirit an entity a unique identity you
are
in that conscious mind and perceiving
the world i say what about the
subconscious mind it's not a creative
mind the subconscious mind is habits
things that you've learned and you
experienced in your life and they become
habits so
the subconscious mind is not thinking
creating a subconscious mind push the
button
play the behavior
so here's the point
when we are in our conscious mind we are
connecting our spirituality to the
biology and the physical planet that
we're in and that is a creative mind
that's the one you wake up in the
morning and say
oh i wish i had this and i desire that
and these are the things i want and then
you go out and start the day and then
guess what
95
of the day
you are not operating from the conscious
mind science has recognized 95
of the day because we are thinking 95 of
the day our behavior is now controlled
by the subconscious mind
i go okay so what's the difference in
the final conclusion of this is the
conscious mind with your creativity has
your wishes and your desires
the subconscious mind was programmed by
other people
your mother your father your siblings
and your community so what is the
difference
you wake up with a wish and a desire of
what you want
and then the rest of the day
you play the programs that you got from
other people that don't answer your
wishes and don't support your desires
and all you see is the consequence of it
and go oh my god why is it not working
the answer is because you don't see
because remember the name is
subconscious
below conscious
so when that behavior is playing
psychologists will tell us
70 percent or more
of the programs in the subconscious
are disempowering
self-sabotaging and limiting behaviors
so the simple reality is this we have
great wishes and desires and yet our
life is not controlled by that our life
is controlled by the programming and
that programming is the disempowering
program so all you see is the
consequence of the invisible
subconscious which will sabotage
all the desires and wishes you have
and then to conclude that
what if you just didn't
default to the subconscious what if you
just stayed in the conscious mind that's
called being mindful
and why is it relevant
because when you stay
conscious keep your mind present
you are the creator of your life and
when people are in mindfulness they
manifest their wishes their desires and
their happiness so for all of us it's
sort of a wake-up call you think you're
running your life with your wishes and
desires it's an illusion i use a diagram
to explain the mind now let this circle
represent your mind
and let this little circle here
represent your body
now i want you to think of this for a
moment
your body is a molecular structure this
is a massive energy and a very high
speed of vibration
if you looked at your body through a
microscope you'd see that energy dancing
right before your eyes
here's something that'll keep you
thinking for the next 20 years when you
move out of it the body does not stop
moving if you go to a funeral parlor and
pick up the remains and look at it you
will see it moving and if it wasn't
moving how would it ever change the dust
you move into your body and you will
move up
and it's how you use your mind that's
going to dictate the vibration you're in
now stay with me
you have an imaginary line right across
here
and that separates the conscious mind
from the subconscious mind
now the subconscious mind has been
programmed
when you were a little baby this is the
way it was you're just like this
subconscious mind wide open and
everything that was going on around it
went right in there
and all the energy that went in there
when you were just a little baby form
something called a paradigm
now a paradigm
is information it's a multitude of
habits you are the product of your
environment but prior to that you are
the product of a genetic strain that
goes back for generations now i'm going
to say that the paradigm is x type
energy
now you've got the ability here on a
conscious level to think
and you can think anything you want to
think
and as you think you build ideas
there's a power that's flowing into your
consciousness it never stops it flows to
and through you you can actually
photograph this power leaving you it
flows to and through you
now as it flows in you will start
thinking and you'll probably think
x-type thoughts
therefore you're going to be in an
x-type vibration
and that will produce
type results now it's the results you
want to change
and to change the results you're going
to have to change what you attract
you see the thoughts that you think
control the vibration that you're in
vibration is nothing but an idea it's a
law of the universe everything vibrates
nothing rests we live in a notion of
motion
and it's the thoughts that you're
thinking that you impress upon your
subconscious mind that control the
vibration the body's in
and that dictates how you act but it
also dictates what you attract
you attract energy that's in harmony
with you you attract people that are in
harmony with you you see everything
operates on frequencies there's a
infinite number of frequencies but you
and i operate on a frequency just like a
radio station does and the only music
you can attract is the music that is
tuned in to the vibration you're in
now it's the paradigm that has been
controlling the vibration
you can change your thinking
but that doesn't do anything you've got
to change the paradigm
and if you don't change the paradigm
nothing happens
now talking about paradigms is another
subject we'll do that at another time
but it's the thoughts that you think
that control the vibration you're in and
that dictates what you attract so if you
keep attracting what you don't want
understand this
it's the paradigm that's causing the
problem you can think a y type thought
which is totally different than the x
type conditioning it isn't going to go
anywhere
because when you go to get emotionally
involved and this is the emotional mind
when you go to get emotionally involved
with that y-type done the paradigm will
kick it out you know why it's so
uncomfortable
that's stepping out of the box that's
doing things different and we don't like
to do things different because it causes
a lot of discomfort
but understand this the paradigm and the
thinking control the vibration you're in
and the vibration is going to dictate
what you attract
people that are in a poverty
consciousness will continue to attract
lack and limitation it has nothing to do
with this what's going on here this is
your educated mind and you could gather
all kinds of information have you ever
wondered why some people have such an
educated mind they have degrees coming
right off the end of their business card
but it doesn't show up in their results
why
paradigm
the law of attraction
you've got to change this
you've got to change the vibration
you're in and your whole world changes
listen
in 1961 a man gave me this book and he
said do exactly what i tell you he was
giving me y type ideas it caused an
enormous amount of discomfort but i did
exactly what he said and you know
something my income went from 4 000 to
175 000 in a year and then i took it
over a million
it took me nine and a half years to
figure out what happened
this is what i'm showing you
watch this over and over and over again
there's a number of lessons in here
and another lesson i'm going to show you
how to change the paradigm when you
change the paradigm the change in
results is automatic you know why you
start to attract something that
something different and what we want to
do
is program in positive information and
eliminate the negative
i'm going to show you how to do that
a law of attraction
you attract according to the vibration
you're in this thing we live in is a
molecular structure your body is a
massive energy you know if you put your
body in front of an infrared television
camera in a completely dark room your
whole being would be nothing but a
glistening radiating gleaming form
feeling is conscious awareness of the
vibration we're in when we don't feel
good
we're in a negative vibration
you want to feel good move into a
positive vibration stop and think of
what you're grateful for
but understand this
you will never attract to you
wealth happiness health until you get
the paradigm and get you on that
frequency tantra means the
technology technology means
when those times when we did not have
any external instruments of technology
we realized the highest grade of
technologies here
and to exercise this
in many different ways
now
if we want to see outside the door
we need a periscope
now somebody found a way to look beyond
without a periscope
using your mind
beyond the realm of your body right now
mind is functioning within the realm of
your body you want to use it there
it is possible to do that it's not not
possible
it's just that
all kinds of wild and absurd things are
believed if you trim those things
in many ways
knowingly or unknowingly many of you are
using this
you create what you want in the world
when you really want it
in a way it's simply your focus which
makes those things happen
maybe it is not as
tangible as it's in a cinema
but
every one of you to some extent you're
doing isn't it
how effectively do you do it
depends on
there are many things if i say
things that happen around me they're too
fairly tailish
i wouldn't believe such nonsense if
anybody told me so i won't tell you
because i don't want you to believe or
disbelieve those things but every day
people around me witness things which
they think is nothing short of a miracle
but there's no miracle
life is a big miracle question is are
you consciously in it
or are you out of it that's a big
question
if you're in it
you're see if you use any thought this
is well he was asking how do we do it in
the beginning
suppose you generate a thought
have you noticed this suppose you
generate a thought
and then you invest your emotion in this
thought suddenly this thought becomes
boom
huh
yes or no
right now i generate a thought oh she's
such a wonderful person
but now i invest my emotion into the
thought now suddenly
you are not just another person to me
you are something else to me
is it reality or no
just because you invested your emotion
into your thought
now there is a next thing
if you invest your life energies into it
consciously
suddenly this will become something else
altogether
suddenly
you become like
life is a play
is no more a struggle
because
miracles are always happening you put a
little seed it becomes a tree he eats a
noodle he becomes a man
i'm saying this is happening to
it's happening all the time just see you
put filth into the root just see it
becomes fragrance
is it is this not miracles and miracles
all over the place
the question is only
are you consciously a part of this
miraculous creation you know many people
come to me and say i want to be a
millionaire i i and there's a great song
about i'm going to be a millionaire and
they read things like the secret which
says if you want to be a millionaire
just just wish it and it will happen
and that's not quite enough i've worked
with many many many millionaires and i
became on myself quite a long time ago
now never having possibly thought that
could ever happen when i was at school
i was going to be a nanny that's how
much i thought i could earn in my
lifetime that's what i thought i was
meant to be but then i worked with so
many multi-millionaires and billionaires
and i really understand
how to attract money how to attract
wealth i'm going to take you through
today
why you haven't yet become a millionaire
there's several things that will stop
you here's the number one
you don't believe you are worth it you
may want money you may long for money
but if you have an inner belief that
says i'm not worth it not only won't you
attract that money if you did you would
get rid of all of it so if you wish to
become a millionaire you must
decide you're worth it the more
reasons you can decide you're worth it
the more you'll have that motivation
that fire that drive to go out
and make a lot of money the second thing
that will make you become and stay a
millionaire
is working out how much good you will do
with the millions that you make you see
bill gates what an amazing guy he says
that in 20 years
malaria won't exist because he is using
his money
to wipe out malaria that's an
extraordinary thing and he deserves all
the wealth he has for that reason alone
if you can think of something that you
could do or
the people you would help an impact by
becoming a millionaire the more reasons
you can come up with the more people you
can help the more reasons you will have
to become and stay a millionaire and
here's the third thing and this is so
important many people think well i'm
just going to float around and manifest
millions i'm just going to sit at home
on my sofa and manifest millions if you
want a job you go out and look for a job
if you want a new home you go out and
visit new homes you want a partner you
better go out and put yourself in front
of people
and if you want to make and keep
millions
you need to decide what are you going to
do
to make those millions what gift or
talent do you have that you can monetize
you may say i don't have anything but
that's not true
if you really take a while you can find
a gift a unique skill set you have that
you could monetize you see some of the
smartest people in the world they don't
invent a product they take an existing
product like james dice and he took a
hair dryer
he took a fan heater he took a vacuum
cleaner he took a hand dryer and he made
them better
and many many people take an existing
product to make it better and become a
millionaire that way it's not about
shall i invent something i don't have an
inventive mind i'm not creative
it's about an idea you may come up with
a new product you may take someone
else's product for instance shapewear
wasn't new when spanx came on the market
and became a
multi-multi-million dollar company they
didn't invent a new product well they
sort of did they took an existing
product they made it so much better
and you can do that too
but the biggest blocks i see with
budding millionaires are these things
one is
i'm going to be a millionaire i'm going
to be a millionaire and they just try
and imagine in the future and the thing
about the mind is the human mind doesn't
future pace very well
one of the reasons depressed people
can't snap out of it is because they
can't future pace and by the way if this
is making sense to you please like
please share please subscribe to my
channel show to other people who also
want to make money why wouldn't you want
to make money you can do great things
for others when you make money but they
don't know how
they've been deluded by these
manifestation rooms sit at home and chan
on shanti and money will fall from the
heavens we all know
that's not true
so if you want money you must be able to
visualize but it must be now you must be
able to think of
how you're going to what could you
possibly do to make money
remember that woman who changed the face
of a floor mop they made a movie about
her and she became a millionaire and she
was a housewife but one day she was
mopping her floor you know this is not
really a good mark and she recreated and
reinvented a floor mop and
has made millions that way
but here's another big block you have to
work hard many people think well i'll
just manifest i just sit at home
the best plan in the world will not work
if you don't work
so people get this really weird belief
that people who make millions don't work
they just manifest it falls from the
heavens they float around doing a little
stuff here and there
and that's not true i work with
millionaires and billionaires and they
do work hard they work long and they
work hard on their way to success they
work a lot when they get success
of course they can take time out but you
see when you do what you love and love
what you do it never really feels like
work i love what i do
i do what i love often say i feel like
i've never worked a day in my life
because i love what i do but really
i have worked out when i've written
books i've been writing for 12 hours a
day meeting deadlines i travel all over
the world through time zones giving
talks and sometimes that's tiring i plan
out my schools and i'm there teaching
but i love it so much it doesn't feel
like work but if you believe
you can be a millionaire
and not have to change anything or do
anything or work hard you will probably
never be a millionaire
you have to work hard you have to apply
yourself the best plan will not work if
you don't you have to have phenomenal
extraordinary self-belief
and finally you have to put yourself
around other people who've made money
ask them what did you do
what happened to you you see i met wayne
dyer many years ago and he said
something always remembered do not die
with your music still inside and i
thought wow
i'm one of the best therapists in the
world and i can't die with my therapy i
mean i need to create a course make a
school teacher to other people i was so
glad i listened to him
and i've listened to many people who say
the same thing i didn't go to university
i didn't have a child background i
wasn't born into money but i had a dream
a vision and i
married that vision to very hard work i
kept going
please don't think successfully will
never get rejected they do but they
bounce back they come back they have
unshakable
unwavering confidence they have drive
and determination
so take a few minutes and just get a
little notebook or on your phone write
out all the reasons why you would like
to be a millionaire
all the good things you could do if you
were a millionaire the people you could
help
and then decide
what industry you could go into you're
going to invent something create
something and some of the smartest
people create things entirely by mistake
look at what other millionaires have
done read some books written by
millionaires there are many
read richard branson reed felix dennis
look at some stories of millionaires and
decide if they can do it i can do it
this is a template
and i'm going to follow that template
and if you have the belief the vision
the work ethic the drive
and the confidence you will become a
millionaire money is the exchange of
values
in fact the way a society spends
money
is
a clue
to their values
so right now most
wealthy nations and even some unwealthy
nations poor nations are spending money
on weapons on mechanized death
on drugs
on alcohol
on gambling
on
sleazy stuff
and that only represents the collective
consciousness
of
um
bad money bad karma
and
therefore
stay away
from
any
way that
generates money
through harm
and this is what
the great teacher of all time
the buddha he said
right livelihood so right livelihood is
that kind of livelihood
that
creates
joy in the world that
increases abundance in the world
increases and improves the quality of
life in the world
okay
understand that when you're exchanging
money you're exchanging values
there's a clear separation between
awareness and the mind we're not the
mind rather we're awareness moving
through different areas of the mind
right so this is the most important
thing that i can share with you and this
is really the core
uh it is the foundation of everything
that i do teach
so once you realize that you're not the
mind but rather that you that rather
that your awareness moving through
different areas of mind you can control
where your awareness goes
and now i want to bring your attention
to another point this is a saying that
my guru said many many decades ago where
awareness goes energy flows right and
you've heard me share this many times as
well online
so once you know that you're not the
mind rather than your awareness and if
you can control where your awareness
goes you can control where your energy
is flowing now let's look at energy
energy is like water right whatever it
is your water will start to grow energy
works the same thing in the same way too
whatever it is you put energy into will
start to manifest in your life so if you
put energy into something negative it'll
grow and manifest in your life you put
energy into something positive it'll
grow and manifest in your life one thing
you want to do is move your awareness
there as you move your awareness to
those goals that's where your energy is
flowing as your energy flows there you
they start to manifest in your life but
one of the things you want to do is to
be mindful and be very conscious of
where you're spending your energy you
only have so much energy each day right
so you want to really assess your life
and look at the people and things in
your life and say okay i've only got
this much energy how can i take this
finite amount of energy that i have
and proportionately divide it into these
people and things
in my life that i care about so that i
can start to manifest them what
manifests in your life is
proportionately
is in proportion to what how much energy
that you're actually investing into
something so if you want something to
manifest in your life put energy into it
how do you put your energy into it you
move your awareness to that thing and
when you move your awareness there where
awareness goes energy flows
and that thing starts to manifest in
your life three things to keep in mind
purpose
focus simplify have a clear purpose
clear goals
focus on those things right focus on
those purposes and those goals
throughout the year always bring your
awareness back to them and simplify your
life simplify your life to the most
important people and the most important
things in your life so that you can take
the finite amount of energy that you
have and invest it into those people and
things into your into your goals to
manifest what you want to manifest in
2019. your energy dictates your results
think about it when you have felt
positive motivated energized ready to go
courageous bold you show up differently
right you show up differently than when
you're feeling depressed that it's not
going to work out
the negative self-talk someone like you
can't do it you're not getting any
momentum you're not getting the results
like think about your own mental state
when you are
[Music]
trying to accomplish a goal and the
difference between when you have
positive energy versus negative energy
it has nothing to do with your skills
has nothing to do with your potential it
has everything to do with how you're
feeling right now
right it's why i say that lack of belief
is the world's number one problem
you don't believe in yourself enough you
don't have the right energy level and so
you don't go off and create even though
you've got it inside you to do it and
you've got the heart and the mission and
the care and the love and you want to do
it
so it's all about changing your energy
states
i think there's a misconception that
people who are high achievers wake up
and just feel energized and motivated
ready to go right today i did not wake
up and say yes
come on
[Music]
let's go take on the day i'm so excited
right that's not how i woke up today i
woke up it was dark outside it's snowing
as you can you can tell here right it's
snowing look at look at what look at
what nina's driving through
stay safe nina
both of our safety depends on it
she's driving through the the snow storm
it's dark outside
and i wake up and and the difference is
i don't i don't put my feet on the
ground to get all jazzed up and start
yelling about what a great day it's
going to be i wake up and i'm tired and
i'm like why is it so dark outside
why we have this snowstorm uh you know
i'm thinking about the call i had
yesterday with brendon burchard on zoom
and he's showing me his
tropical
puerto rican beach backdrop and i got
canadian snow happening here right now
the difference is
the people who you admire who have the
success who are the high achievers they
don't wake up
like there's a superhuman and extra
motivated
they're just like you the difference is
they have the habits and the routines
where they demand the energy from
themselves they create the energy for
themselves and so there's there's two
things that i want you to start thinking
about how do you do it right like okay
great heaven how do i do it how do i
actually change my energy how do i get
it so that i am feeling powerful bold
motivated confident excited on a daily
basis because it is possible and because
you know how great you feel and you know
the results that you get when you're
feeling that way so two things that i
want you to keep in mind the first one
is
having
something in your morning routine that
demands that from you so for me music is
the fastest way to change my state music
i have a playlist called the believe
playlist um it's hashtag believe all
caps on my main channel you can go find
it that's the music i listen to every
day that may not be the thing that gets
you fired up
but it is for me
music is the fastest way to change your
state because there are some songs that
when they come on when you hear them
it just makes you want to move you might
get up and dance you might just be
nodding your head you might be tapping
your foot but there are some songs that
come on that make you want to move it
can't just be the same song every day
because then you're going to get sick of
it and bored of it but you make a
playlist of the different music that
when it comes on
it forces you to shift your state
we often put on the music for how we
currently feel
so when you're sad and low and depressed
or upset you put on music that makes you
feel
reinforced and you're sad and low and
depressed and upset states
when you're sad and low you don't put on
music to make you feel better you put on
music to keep you where you are that's
the problem that that then what it keeps
you where you are
right when you put on the music
for how you currently feel it keeps you
where you are where what you want to do
is use music to shift your state so when
you're feeling not so motivated when
you're feeling tired when you're feeling
low you put on music that gets you up
and what's going to happen you're going
to feel a little bit more up so putting
that as a part of your daily routine
daily daily daily daily daily daily
daily daily daily daily daily daily
routine it matters it makes a difference
if you if you started your day with
music that would make you feel
energized pumped up motivated ready to
go if you started your day with that
your day will look different your days
will look different your weeks will look
different your months will look
different and the things that you
accomplish will look dramatically
different okay so that's a daily basis i
need you to shift your morning routine
to incorporate something like that just
try it try for a week and see how you
feel it'll make a difference i promise
step number two is
reacting to the moment so that's what we
do in step number one is what we do on a
daily basis in the morning step number
two is when we have something that
we come across that
makes us feel
less confident that makes us feel scared
that is a big opportunity that makes us
question ourselves doubt ourselves when
you look at your calendar you look at
your emails you look at the results and
you see that you're not where you want
to be
the tendency is to beat ourselves up the
tendency is to play scared the tendency
is to act small the tendency is to
procrastinate and go do something else
right you know i've been there you've
been there maybe you are there right now
you know what i'm talking about
energy
is now the reason why we're staying
where we are so how do we shift our
energy
in those moments
one remind yourself that you do
difficult things
you do difficult things
that if it's hard if it's scary that
it's difficult you're gonna do it you're
gonna do it you're gonna show up you're
gonna do it because you do difficult
things
it cuts the brain out of the equation
because now it's time to show yourself
what you can do
instead of overthinking over
procrastinating
and being overly scared
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome if you want to learn how
the law of attraction works check the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there so when you think a
deliberate thought of what you want
then law of attraction will employ the
universe
and all people circumstances and events